do whatever you want
but don't do it in front of children
is it is that so hard
is it really so hard
i'm i'm not in favor of pulling
anybody's sexual activities or
kinks or whatever under some kind of
prohibition
but i don't think it's unreasonable to
say
let's not expose children to it
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today who
we've been after for a long time and
we're delighted to have him on the show
he's an american journalist andrew
sullivan welcome to trigonometry thank
you so much it's an honor to be here
it's a great pleasure to have you on the
show uh we know who you are and we love
your writing and your work a lot of our
audience do as well they've been asking
us to have you on the show for a long
time but for those who don't know you or
your backstory who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
through life that lead you to be sitting
here talking to us
that's a wild and woolly story really i
i grew up um and in east queenston
uh i know it well
you do
yes i live close to that i play
basketball there yeah oh really how
wonderful oh and i used to go to school
in red hill for a bit
you did well i went to wrigley grammar i
went to some beads
well there you go it's just it's a small
right let's end the interview we can
just exchange locations
so i grew up there i went to rugged
grammar i was i was sat next to kia
stammer for five years and we uh
we notoriously fought each other every
day on the 428 bus he was a a lefty
communist i was a i was a young
thatcherite and we went at it we were
that's i mean that's another part of my
story then i went to got a scholarship
to go to
oxford started history got a scholarship
to go to harvard did political
philosophy there and then i got an
internship at the new republic magazine
which at that time was kind of like the
spectator in london or fusion of the
spectator a new statesman
uh which was an incredible opportunity
for me to understand america i fell in
love with the place
i went back and forth did my phd then
surprise surprise at 26 they made me the
editor of the new republic which i did
for five more years which was uh an
exhilarating if crazy experience um
2000 i um
i started my blog daily dish i now have
a sub stack the weekly dish i worked
for the atlantic and
new republic and new york magazine new
york times magazine and i was
uh
the first person to really put marriage
equality on the map i guess and wrote
the first book in defense of marriage
equality for for gays and lesbians
called virtually normal
um and later i wrote a book called the
conservative soul um my dissertation was
on oakshot the british conservative
philosopher um who died a year after i
finished my dissertation
um so that's that'll cause a link there
is that what you're suggesting
yes one last look at my dissertation he
thought it was all over uh
it was actually the only second
dissertation ever written about him and
he actually invited me at the end of it
to talk to him in his cottage in dorset
which was really a wonderful wonderful
day to meet your idol to meet the person
you've been reading for a year and a
half and he didn't disappoint
and andrew as as i hear you talking i
hear someone who is in love with
journalism who has spent a lifetime uh
in this profession
i'm afraid if you were to poll the
general public i would suggest that that
love is not currently widely shared
uh and we've seen over a long period of
time now that
some strange things have been happening
in the world of mainstream media and
journalism in particular
what is going on in your opinion in that
world
well it's it's been in a serious crisis
i think for quite a while um
my own experience with what happened is
it it kind of shifted in the mid 20
teens
something around 2014 2015 something
seemed to happen
i think it was a combination of two
things one
the media was in top trouble
economically i mean it was they were
terrified of going under
they couldn't afford what they had been
doing so they then reached out and they
were terrified by the web so then they
reached out to young
college graduates to come and help them
out uh and they let a hell of a lot of
them in and they were all freshly
indoctrinated uh in various elements of
critical theory and had the habits of
elite college campuses and they swiftly
began to turn
newsrooms into the equivalent of these
nightmarish college campuses which have
a kind of reign of terror fear of of a
fear of uh
wrong think fear of contrary ideas a
belief that speech itself
writing itself words somehow are harmful
that they are the equivalent of sticks
and stones
uh and the dynamic emerged in these
newsrooms in which these younger
staffers
would be incredibly
absolutist about what they were
demanding
uh
wanted a totally different staff based
on different gender sex
uh race et cetera wanted stories written
again now without any attempted
objectivity the goal was to change the
world through the methods of of critical
theory and uh
and the
desperate
aging allegedly liberal editors
uh caved
uh there's something about calling
an older liberal person in america a
racist that will make them do anything
you want them to do
and
once they figured this out
once they figured out the absolute
insecurity of these of this older
generation
they just went to town um i mean i
personally i was at new york magazine i
went back into the msm after being an
independent blogger for a long time
uh and
i began to write what i thought about
some of the
sort of excessive tactics
of for example the metoo movement
uh not that i was in any way uh opposed
to changing the atmosphere about sexual
harassment and treatment of women in the
workplace which i supported entirely but
the notion that you could just simply
slander people without evidence as
rapists and uh and sexual assault
artists without any actual proof struck
me as terrible so i wrote pieces saying
i disagree with that and sure enough
pretty soon a young swath of staffers
uh decided that simply publishing my
columns
created an unsafe work environment for
them
and went to hr
to get me to get rid of me um and
i didn't work in the office i work at
home hundreds of miles away from where
they are but i was creating an unsafe
work environment because my ideas were
harming them now this went on for a
while until eventually summer of 2020
when i could not and would not
praise the rioting after the blm uh
movement or the violence and wanted to
write a column criticizing the violence
they asked me not to write and i said
okay and but at that point it was
beginning to unravel and eventually they
turned around a couple of weeks later
and and fired me
and so then i started the weekly dish
which is a sort of weekly version of
what i used to do
and uh the good news is it's it's it's
great it's doing really well i enjoy it
i don't have to worry anymore
about putting my foot in it um
if readers don't like what they're
reading they can always unsubscribe
every week
to create a sort of atmosphere of
liberal open debate i have dissents
strong powerful defense against what i
wrote the previous week which i am
required to answer which are selected by
my colleague chris so it's a
and we're doing great my salary actually
this is why i'm not i'm not whining
about council culture because even
though i was cancelled i did incredibly
well from it i tripled my salary
uh overnight uh
but uh
you see this dynamic in the newsrooms
you see an urge for what they call moral
clarity which means that abandoning any
pretense of presenting both sides
you have a younger generation using
journalism as a form of social justice
activism not
actual relaying of news or a diversity
of opinion now i happen to think at this
point
things may be beginning to shift back
uh and and i think we've seen some signs
this week of that actually happening i i
in the washington post which is one of
the workers of the woke
uh they finally had it and fired
one of the most uh troublemaking and uh
passionate and fanatical social justice
activists on staff
uh after she had engaged in a week-long
parade against her colleagues accusing
them of
many many different crimes but
especially that of being white which was
apparently the one thing the one thing
you
you you you're allowed to demonize
people for so eventually she was fired
as of friday
um last friday which would be well early
june
um and
i sense
a little bit of a vibe shift
i sense the fact that readers are really
not only kind of offended by some of
this screechy
partisan subjective journalism in in
replacement but are bored by it i mean
it's you you look at the new york times
and you'll see
a dozen different columns so basically
they're all saying the same thing
and ultimately this has kind of led
people to move away
um and has led to the great flourishing
of sub-stack
and the existence of sub-sac and
independent source information is
beginning i believe to affect the
judgment of some of these uh other
organizations uh and they're beginning
to
restabilize the thing that i always find
and then let's look at the washington
post which is owned by jeff bezos
a man who has been in my view
legitimately criticized
for
the treatment and the conditions of the
people in his factories
and depots and we've actually had
independent journalists come on and
criticize him
and criticize the practices of amazon
yet these people who describe themselves
as woke work for the for the washington
post and they see no problem at all in
working for jeff bezos whereas the
traditional old school left that i used
to identify with
they wouldn't work for him because they
would say the old treatment of workers
is
incorrect wrong inhuman whatever word
they would want to use to describe it
and they wouldn't do it but these people
have no problem taking basos dollar and
yet
purporting to be more moral than you or
i or anybody else well they're not that
interested in the plight of
working-class people actually
in terms of economics if jeff bezos
didn't have enough african-americans on
his staff if he didn't have enough women
then they might get angry about it
but that's the real twist of this and of
course
jeff bezos by going woke
in this way i'm i'm of course i'm not
entirely sure how fully aware he is of
what's going on in his media properties
um
but uh if he if if it's this is the
dynamic isn't it of work capitalism is
that you
you you you you distract people with
this
uh identity politics
in order to justify and defend your own
exploitative sometimes incredibly uh
almost victorian work policies because
you but now you're a good person because
you you're politically correct and you
are woke and you are have have more
african-americans on your staff and you
you run stories that are full of uh
references to white supremacy and
uh the rest of it so it's a kind of
laundering as it were
of a certain kind of economic inequality
uh of a protest against that in favor of
uh this uh identity politics and that's
a struggle that the left is going to
have to figure out for itself
there's a beginning of it you know the
marxists over here
the best critique of the 1619 project
was done by the old school marxists
and increasingly even though i'm a
conservative i kind of like those people
because they they're talking about
something real they're talking about
economics they're talking about
inequality talking about how do you
protect workers of any race
and i think there's a sense that there's
been a complete distraction from that
and
and that's beginning to be why when you
look at the polling in america and you
look at the election results of the last
few years you are seeing a really quite
interesting shift
towards the republicans from minority
groups
because the best example of luxury white
woke beliefs
hurting
african americans for example
is the defunder police movement
and the decision to demonize the cops in
america that the people who have
suffered from that
who have suffered from the drawback
of policing
a black latino often immigrant
communities that are facing crime
every day on their own streets crime
that has soared in the last two years
while white wealthy liberals in their
gated estates
tell them it's good for them that we
need to overhaul our white supremacist
system they are dying because of that
the kids are being shot
the the murder rate has gone up
staggeringly and it's concentrated
in these particular areas of poverty
which tend to overlap
with with racial discrimination too
and so you're beginning to see i think
a real shift underneath uh politics in
this country and i uh and i think the
whole notion
that for example the democrats will
ultimately win in america because they
represent the non-white
and the non-white are growing
proportionally
is slowly being dismantled as an idea
uh we can see that latinos are no
different than previous waves of
immigrants who just want to assimilate
want to take part in the american dream
didn't come here
from places like venezuela or cuba
to set up socialism they they've
despised it they know what it means and
uh
you know the little little side richie
taurus he's a brilliant young
uh congress person from new york city
uh puerto rican i think i hope i got
that right um
uh actually openly gay
uh who came out the other last week and
said can we please stop using this term
latinx
it just completely
you're trying to tell latin culture that
there's no male and female are you out
of your [ __ ] mind i mean
the language is divided into male and
female with spinary language and so
instead of saying latino or latina
they have to say latinx and you know and
you have you know biden joe biden saying
latin x in a speech and like that dude
has never said that word in private in
the entire history of his life
well not least because he hasn't existed
for most of his life but andrew it's
interesting to hear you describe
yourself as a conservative uh because
when i read your column i i get a quite
a strong liberal bent from a lot of what
you say too
and of course during the trump era you
were
widely accused of having trump
derangement syndrome and
and all of that so
what what do you mean when you describe
yourself as a conservative
someone who believes in
avoiding drastic ideological change
someone who believes in the organic
development of society someone who
believes in the defense
of institutions
of the rule of law
of tradition generally speaking
um and that is why
a conservative defense of trump is
simply impossible
he was an a direct radical threat to
very basic democratic norms
we now know this this this person tried
to ferment a essentially
uh preventing a peaceful transfer of
power uniquely
uh
anti-institutional
uh
radical subversive attack
on the practices that make a country
work
and that define a country
when someone is attacking the very heart
of a liberal democracy
what do you mean specifically sorry to
interrupt because francis and i haven't
followed the hearings that are going on
right now particularly closely uh when
you're talking about him undermining
these institutions what do you mean
specifically
i mean insisting that the rule of law
applies only to him that if if the rule
of law goes against him he will fire the
attorney general i mean clearly plotting
to have electors from the states
that had already selected joe biden to
reverse their votes
actually helping organize violence
to to stop the the past the passing of
power from trump to biden
uh this is
staggering sending
violent
armed men
into
the sacred citadel of american democracy
to bully and coerce people into
reversing
a legitimate election result
there is no greater crime
to be done against a liberal democracy
and there may be
and there are and i've said too that
there are some issues that trump raised
that are important that liberals have
failed to raise
uh for example obviously immigration
the effect of free trade on whole
sections of the american society
these are things that he was right to
point out and he deserves credit
for pointing those things out but that
cannot
legitimize legitimize the way he
conducted himself in office
his attempt to undermine our democracy
which places him uniquely
as the most destructive president in
american history and i say that as a
conservative
no conservative wants to destroy the
institutions
of liberal democracy or wants to impugn
the entire system as a fraud
andrea
i'm glad we have this strong critique of
trump on the show i think it's really
important particularly from your
position and francis and i were both
very concerned as outside observers
about what happened on january ii we
were unquestionably critical of those
events what do you say to the
counterpoints and i think there are two
counterpoints to what you're saying uh
the first is yes donald trump was a
radically transformational candidate but
the reason people voted for him was that
they felt that the status quo was not
working and the republican party such as
it was uh this this whole the chokehold
that the two parties had without
offering actual genuine change that
people were concerned about that is why
trump was elected and so in attempting
to deliver some of that radical change
she was being democratic the first point
and the second point you know i i agree
with you that i think sending or
encouraging people or even allowing
people to be in a position to storm the
capital in the way that they did was
attempting to interfere with the
democratic process and i think that's
completely wrong
what about the banning of the hunter
biden story from being shared on the big
tech platforms was that not election
interference that had i mean the studies
showed that it had an impact on on
people's voting preferences for example
there is a clear and bright distinction
between
stories
i mean first of all i agree with you
that was a disgraceful
act the the idea that it was also
function of russian uh
intelligence was also [ __ ] i did not
buy a lot of the russian the russian
conspiracy [ __ ] that went on for a
long time and you can check my record on
that i was always skeptical about that
um
but they're not equatable there is
nothing
that can be equated with an attempt to
undermine knowingly because now we know
that every single person around him told
him he'd lost this election he still
went on
to attempt to and could have
if it in any way succeeded destabilize
this country massively and would have
welcomed that destabilization there is
no restraining instinct in donald trump
he would destroy anything
rather concede he was wrong
he is manically going around the country
still insisting not only he won the
election but he won it by a landslide
he is trying to get a political party to
invalidate
the results of a democratic election
this is this is so far outside anything
acceptable
that it must be forbidden
he is a stain
on american history and on the american
constitution
uh listen to him he's out of his mind
you can't let someone like that in a
position of power we were lucky to get
away with it for four years in fact we
weren't lucky because he nearly
destroyed the whole system
uh you can be and should be in my view a
great critic of the way that
liberal in its neo-liberal elites right
and left
forgot a lot of human beings in our
society
and enacted policies and refused to
correct them that hurt people
you can say that some of the issues that
trumpism represents should be
represented and i think the republican
party is moving in that direction
but you can't get around this crazy
person
uh you know human individual humans do
affect history
and i do think he's the most uniquely
dangerous person who's arrived
in american politics in my lifetime by
easily
hey kkk do you believe in spring
cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in russia men who clean are executed
for not being real men which is correct
well for those men who are living in the
21st century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the waist grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package 4.0
inside this care bundle you'll find lawn
mower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear and
nose hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant crop provider turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of boris johnsons treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
and what would you say to the
this is my view on trump that trump is a
system
oh sorry sorry yeah a symptom of the
fact that the system no longer works for
the average american voter there are
huge swipes of people in america who
look at left and right and go
this isn't working you're not going to
help me you don't represent me you
represent the interests of big business
and corporations and whoever i vote for
i'm going to end up in the same position
so it doesn't matter if i vote for the
crazy radical because even if the system
goes to pot i'm going to still be in the
exact same place
yes except you'll notice that
biden for example
has largely adopted most of the trade
policies that trump
pursued um
biden has pulled out of afghanistan
something that trump promised but never
did there are continuities here because
policy issues have shifted
um and you'll see republicans themselves
uh actually prepared to engage in some
minimal redistribution
uh some controls on on trade and
it has made a difference these and trump
deserves credit i'm not going to deny
this for bringing those issues to the
fore
but characterologically
he is incapable and proves himself
incapable to be president of a
democratic society he just is incapable
of it
oh what
you don't you don't don't don't see how
monstrous this person is i mean
aren't you i'm ashamed to be a country
which had this person as president it's
a massive embarrassment
i would say as well look there's things
i disagree with trump absolutely and i
thought ultimately he was a very toxic
individual and the divisiveness that he
brought to america was was dangerous
but i also
look at the system that created him and
i blame the system and i blame the left
above all
for
saying that they represent people and
represent working-class people whilst
deep down if i'm being honest and i'm
going to use industrial language not
giving a flying [ __ ] about them
and it's their fault
well they definitely bear a great deal
of responsibility for this and also in
the media in obscuring and lighting the
real questions that people had i agree
with you totally but i don't believe the
whole system is
is finished i do think that in america
there are plenty of ways in which this
can be
changed through democratic
elections we're seeing for example all
over america's school board elections in
which some of the craziest
indoctrination that's been proposed is
being reigned back in by ordinary people
using democracy we're going to have an
election a midterm election very soon
uh which will probably show i think a
republican landslide in both houses
forcing biden to some correction i do
not believe that a system that has has
been through rocky patches but has
survived over 200 years
is to be junked
because we've hit a moment where our
elites have been out of sync with what
most people want that is to be expected
in any country in periods of time trump
deserves credit for breaking that but
now we have to move forward with our
system
find a republican who could represent
them and not be insane and hostile to
our very democratic system and a
democrat who can possibly be what biden
said he was going to be which is take
the take the country back to the center
and i think the center in america is
there still it's quiet
but the party that can occupy it first
is going to win
big that that's very true and look we
weren't actually planning to spend a
huge amount of time talking about trump
but uh it comes back a little bit to the
conversation we were having about
journalism because another perhaps point
that i would agree with francis where
trump was a bit of a symptom is he was
really the only guy
who could survive
what journalists do to republican
leaders
when they run for office which is he's
the only guy who could survive being
called a racist the sexist the homophobe
and all those things and still win
because everybody else just gets labeled
as a nazi and they never recover
and and that was again one of the the
points that i thought was was accurate
about trump is i thought he was a very
toxic personality and and you could see
it you know we were actually sitting in
just a quick anecdote we were sitting
around at the studio on our youtube uh
we were watching something on youtube
and without us knowing the next video it
came on and it was like a compilation of
trump put downs uh and i think a lot of
people were watching it with like
enjoying the but it was all about him
like going go back to mummy or something
and he just it was very very dark it was
dark i i don't question that at all i
just wonder whether a more moderate
person was able to
to break through
the the chokehold that the liberal
mainstream media have on like deciding
whether you're an evil bigger or not
well it all depends whether people buy
that description and over over long time
fortunately trump in some ways was not
innocent of some of the things he was
charged with whereas if you look at
someone like glenn young the republican
governor of virginia who won uh an
election no he wasn't you could call in
these things but he didn't give them
ammunition
uh in fact there's evidence that he and
the the i the what trump did in so many
ways
was was was give credence
to the left look they're a bunch of
racists look he hates immigrants look he
says all these things it
the fight against wokeness was in my
view crippled by the fact that he was
against it because he seemed to
legitimate every single left-wing idea
of what a right-wing person was
if you can have more moderate
conservatives come forward and say for
example yes i'll give you one simple
example transgender people
exist they deserve absolute civil rights
they already have them actually under
boston we need to respect transgender
people
but we shouldn't at the same time forget
that they are biological differences
and in sport in some areas a few that
makes a difference like sports
uh and we should let we should be
extremely careful
in having children
make lifelong decisions about whether
they're a boy or a girl before they've
even hit puberty
and
now you you are more credible
i believe if you can make those nuanced
distinctions
defend trans rights
but engage some of the difficult
uh questions that they bring up
uh than if you just become this
uh person who says that all these trans
people are just mentally ill making [ __ ]
up there's nothing there it's [ __ ]
and
i think that the the nuanced message is
actually has more traction in the
country at large because i actually
don't think most people hate trans
people oh of course no effect of hate is
ridiculous
uh they're uncomfortable but they can
come to terms with it and generally
speaking they support the rights of
trans people
they have issues with their kids
being taught at the age of three
they can choose to be a boy or a girl or
both or neither or something else
entirely like an alien this is insane
and and and it's being pushed back and
it should be pushed back
uh and a lot of us within the gay
community i won't use that term lgbtqia
plus plus because it's it's [ __ ] uh
it is
it
i sometimes people call me lgbtq person
yeah why do you say that why is it
[ __ ]
because
because first of all no one can be an
lgbtq person literally i mean you can't
be a lesbian and a gay and a trans and a
crow whatever
uh secondly
there is no community as such
uh even with gays and lesbians i'm
talking to you from provincetown which
is about as gay as you can get
yes lesbians and gay men live here
happily alongside each other
but the way the oil and water can be
mixed up together you know they have
completely different ways of life very
different subcultures huge different
problems
uh
because one of them
or almost all men
you know with the effect of being a man
quadrupled which means you try getting a
long-standing monogamous relationship
let me know you straight men can't
manage it when you've only got when you
when you have other men in the
relationship good luck similarly there
are no big std outbreaks among lesbians
who are not worried about them getting
monkey pox right now
because they have a completely different
way of life
uh and transgender people are a
completely different set altogether
the the transgender experience could not
be more different than the gay
experience
uh one simple illustration of this when
you were a little gay boy you're growing
up
it seems to me one of the most important
things you need to do is to own the fact
that you are a boy you are a man and you
can love others that's crucial
if you're a trans kid the important
thing is disowning
that you're a man
or a boy and
if you give the same message to gay boys
and trans boys you're actually
engaging in some horrible kind of
conversion therapy for gay kids
the last thing you want to say to a gay
boy for example is you know maybe you're
a girl
when you hear it that way
doesn't it affect you does it make you
feel i mean i will never forget uh at
christmas i was at my grandparents and
my uh my younger brother i was eight he
was kind of four he was bashing a truck
around and i was reading a book and my
grandmother looked at the two boys and
looked at my mother and she said well
pointing to my brother
well at least now you have a real boy
and
that
is roughly
what some of these trans activists are
effectively telling young gay boys
it's what some people are calling trans
or trans away the gay yeah yes and
it's so true because when i was a
teacher and towards the end of my of my
stint as a teacher my
the last time i taught in school was
2020 and i'd been teaching at this point
for around well about 12 years
and
kids now started to identify as you know
trans or
gender fluid etc and i remember i taught
one boy and i got informed that he's
he's seeing himself as trans
and i started teaching him and i go oh
no you're not you're just gay and you
just having to come to terms with it
that's that's what it was which is why
francis has never taught in the school
again yeah exactly that was not enough
but
that is very worrying it's incredibly
worn because
children are vulnerable they just are
that's why there's safeguardings in
place that's why we protect them but
especially a child who is becoming aware
of their own sexuality which is
incredibly difficult and painful for
everybody
adolescence is awful for everyone and
yet now we've got this extra thing on
top
yeah it's it's bewildering for kids i
think and they've also been told they
can call themselves basically anything
you can invent a million different
genders for yourself
uh i think it's particularly tough on
gay children myself
and i cannot understand why gay
organizations are not concerned about
this can't even acknowledge that there
is a trade-off here
80 percent of kids with gender dysphoria
we find out
end up gay
puberty itself
is itself a real affirmation of your
actual biological sex
i i remember being a little worried i
was a gay boy i did not i was a nerd i
was a swat
uh i definitely didn't like contact
sports they forced me to play rugby i
really did not like it uh
uh and
uh where was i so now i've lost my chat
hold on i was gonna say you were saying
how the gay kids are the most affected
by all of this yeah uh
i was going to say something else sorry
it's all good do you mind if i ask you a
different question yes and if it comes
back no i don't mind we'll recover it
yeah perfect so what it's one of one of
the things you're talking about is
actually a concern of mine
because as you start to see this
so-called lgbtqi
plus plus minus up down left right
whatever it is community
start to get involved in things that
would concern a lot of people uh we've
seen
images of drag shows which no one had a
problem with
you know in the last 10 years
now start to be performed to children
[Music]
feeling like a woman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah baby
we had a show here in the uk called the
family sex show which involved
full frontal
nudity
targeted at children from the age of
five upwards
and
it's and other components of that nature
within that and one of the things you're
starting to see now i think from some of
the research i've shown is acceptance
for sexual minorities
going down
including among young people
now to me for someone like you not only
because of your sexuality but because
you were at the forefront of uh
legitimizing marriage equal marriage for
sexual minorities
you've got to be concerned about this
don't you
i am i mean i've been concerned and
and i'm also
worried that the atmosphere that these
activists create
uh terrorize
gay people into
accepting every single crazy thing
um
look
i take the view of mr slave on south
park uh which is that
do whatever you want
but don't do it in front of children
is it is that so hard
is it really so hard
i'm not in favor of pulling anybody's
sexual activities or
kinks or whatever under some kind of
prohibition
but i don't think it's unreasonable to
say
let's not expose children to it and to
be honest with you the vast majority of
gay people feel the same way we do i
feel like we're being grotesquely
misrepresented
by
lgbtqia plus plus organizations
who are essentially at this point uh
incapable of doing anything but react
tribally
to any criticisms of any aspect
of
the
culture of
minority sexualities although i wouldn't
call transgender sexuality but uh it's
not
yeah i mean i
i know lots of drag queens
um i'm surrounded by them here it's it's
like they like carpenter ants um
but uh and they're friends of mine and
you know the best ones are totally not
risque in sexual terms at all they're
like clowns they're like a pantomime
dame i mean we take children to
pantomimes
to
which are essentially drag shows
uh at least in what some aspect musical
drag shows and we don't think that's
abusing them
so there's a fine line here you know you
can have a fun completely
family-friendly drag queen
who can be funny who can engage just
like a pantomime dame or a clown and
then you have the more the more
less talented frankly more vulgar and
more sexualized
uh versions um and
again i took i took my
uh
seven-year-old and five-year-old niece
and nephew to see one of these drag
queens a few years ago
she she didn't they loved it it's
hilarious there was no sexuality
yeah unless you saw the back of this
guy's uh dress which was full of black
hair i mean which deliberately done just
kind of send up drag queens
um
so it again it's complicated and i i
wish
the more responsible ones uh
uh
push back against some of this um you
know and rupaul did a huge i mean
i don't think it's i don't think drag
queens are the great terrible threat
people saying they are is what i would
say i do think
that public authorities public schools
telling children that they can pick
which sex they are is
infinitely more concerning oh i agree
with you andrew but um i
the thing is though and i think you'll
appreciate this
the general public are not as into these
issues and they're not as involved in
the details and the nuances and whatever
so i'm going to ask you quite an
unpleasant and layman question about it
which is look if i am a parent which i
now am
of a child and i'm looking at this
without delving deeply into it i'm not
going to these drag queens and that drag
queens and there's a spectrum and some
of them do this and you you're just
looking at and going why are as you said
yourself children being so shown
sexualized material right
where is this coming from in your
opinion why are people doing this at all
well i think there was a a genuine good
faith idea that that that drag queens
are like clowns
the children relate to them in that way
um and that
having somebody read in the library
which i think is where the stuff started
uh to children in funny outfits might
actually be a completely banal and
rather benign thing
but
some have exploited it and
and i think also
this concept of
lgbtqia plus plus whatever
has created a culture which is now
something that people are saying they
can choose
so so
the majority it turns out the biggest
uh proportion of the people calling
themselves
lgbtqia plus plus in america are
straight people
uh mainly straight women calling
themselves bisexual some 40
in one poll of people identifying as
lgbtq are straight so it's become this
kind of all-purpose trendy uh catch-all
and so and there are some lefty liberal
parents that sort of want their kids to
be part of the lgbtqia because at least
that's not straight i mean look i'm not
defending this i can't defend it i think
it's whacked but you know parents have
control of the children if they want to
take them there if if some kid is taken
to a sexually thing which they haven't
explicitly had consent for from their
parents i think it's an outrage
but i do think
most drag queens are not like that
andrew we're not saying that and we're
not trying to pin it on you we're just
trying to have a conversation because
because the reason is that you see and
you will know this because you are
online and you see the discourse and the
way it moves there is this concern
particularly on the right
this whole groomer conversation which i
find kind of like difficult and i don't
get what's going on exactly but there is
a growing concern that as part of this
increasing tolerance we're now
tolerating things that just frankly
shouldn't be tolerated
i think that's a completely legitimate
concern
but there is a distinction between that
concern
and saying that any teacher that teaches
the syllabus
is attempting to sexually abuse your
child
that seems to be to be a reach that is
ugly
you know calling someone a pedophile is
a bit like calling them a racist
it's something you just can't defend
yourself against it is a a totally
uh totalitarian tactic i think if you if
you don't think people should be called
racist because they have different views
than you which are legitimate views
then you shouldn't be calling people who
have a different view than you do
on on the question of sexual minorities
to be a pedophile the first word out of
your your mouth and look there is a long
history of gay people being called
pedophiles uh and being equated with
them and
we have it in
in
and you know not so long ago the 70s
there was an attempt to get all gay
teachers fired which would in california
and the the politician that actually did
most to prevent that coming into
force it was called the briggs
initiative was
governor ronald reagan who said no
you make a distinction you judge people
by the way they teach not who they are
if there is if there is some abuse and
there is abuse in schools we know this i
mean but it's not always associated with
with gay people and it shouldn't be
associated with a particular kind of
curriculum i think it's cheap and ugly
and i think we can avoid it but you can
still make the case
let us
keep children out of politics
let them
let them see the world for what they
leave them the [ __ ] alone
let them grow up and stop getting into
their heads about this that and the
other um
in the private sphere you can do that
you can bring up your kids as jehovah's
witnesses you can do whatever you want
but in the public sphere public
authorities
teaching kids things that are extremely
dubious for political motives no
and and
i'm sorry
it's it's a little wishy-washy i don't
mean to be wishy-washy i mean to be fair
andrew it's look it's a really really
really important point and thank you for
putting that across with nuance
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com forward slash
triggered that's easy dns dot com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter access of easy which
tells you everything you need to know
about technology
privacy and censorship
i think the problem is andrew i think
we're politicizing everything and this
is the inevitable result of what happens
when you politicize sexuality and sex
yeah i mean at some point
uh
when gay people had no
very few civil rights and were subject
to a great deal of
persecution um
yes you have to be political to get to a
great equality but the point of that
politics was to let go of politics
afterwards was to get on with our lives
once you have formal civil equality
i think you should let the world evolve
in its own way without trying to coerce
it indoctrinate it move it in any which
way that's why i consider myself a
conservative and if people i mean
honestly people understand what i mean
by that i do have a book called the
conservative soul which is available and
it is my attempt to kind of explain
exactly where i think that conservative
temperament belongs
and it is it is present in in
conservatives in britain and america but
currently it's it's in eclipse to more
radical and uh and
revolutionary uh
uh movements i think
and the problem is as well when you
politicize
you create like we've touched on before
this idea of community the gay community
thinks this no they don't
gay men have a variety of difficult of
different political opinions left right
center and so they should they're
individuals you can't just put them on
this under this umbrella this is part of
my problem with the left
it is the left told me
you can't exist
how can you be a homosexual and believe
in god how can you be a homosexual and
adopt a conservative politics you know
the thing about gays especially
is that we are born randomly across
every country so we're going to have
lots of gays in red states and blue
states
as many gays being born in oklahoma as
there are in new york state
per capita
so of course you're going to have the
most diverse political community a third
of gays voted for trump
uh
many of us many of the most important
homosexuals in american history have
been on the right
of course this is the who
as someone rather crudely put it to me
what makes you hard has nothing to do
with what your politics are it's it's a
completely involuntary thing whereas
your politics have to be constructed so
of course you if it irritates you to
hear the lgbt community is offended by
this
they imagine we're just the people i
mean we're absolutely [ __ ] livid of
course we're not offended we're not
offended by dave chappelle we love dave
chappelle if you look at the people
fighting back against some of this crap
glenn greenwald barry weiss
all these people men disproportionately
gay people are fighting back against
this because and this is part of what
the gay tradition is we were never the
senses we were never the skulls we were
never telling people what to do with
their lives our message for so long was
do what you want to do
just leave us alone let us do what we
want to do on some equal footing in
under the law that's all
the idea that it's turned into this
puritanical
censoring scolding humorless
movement is so depressing and it's so
violates our traditions
violates our ultimate culture which is
one of celebration of variety
of the the treasure of the eccentric the
the support of the outsider
the the love of art that can subvert and
change and i tell you it's still here
um not to offend you but i went to a
good drag show one here that comes every
week there's a sort of talent andrew
we're not offended by drag shows
we used to perform with drag people
we've got friends who do drag shows um
we were talking about this yeah all
right
i'm not homophobic all right
he's russian it's not his fault it's his
idea it's my culture
my view as a homo is that i assume
everyone's homo friendly unless proven
otherwise yeah
and my view as a member of minority is
that i do not get up every day wondering
who hates me
i get up every day seeing who loves me
and who i can be with
and uh how i can best live my life and
there are many many more of us out there
and
you boy you you know
the truth is that when you do what i've
done that the most
the most vicious
hostility comes from the gay left
uh i have i mean my first book on
marriage equality was picketed
by lesbian avengers
i've had drinks thrown at me i've been
called the antichrist my second book was
reviewed and said if you hate gay men
you'll love this book the attempt to
delegitimize
non-leftist gays is so well organized
and well oiled it can take a huge amount
look what happened to barry weiss for
example
uh you that you are particularly
vulnerable to attack
so
that's how they enforce the orthodoxy
but people should not believe
the gays and lesbians
not necessarily part of the same
community but that they do not have an
incredibly variety of views they
disagree with each other and the
conversation privately for example about
getting kids to change their sex among
gay men
it is it is it is not happy people are
people are actually faced we've got lots
of gay friends here that we talked to
about this
men and women
none of them are happy about this whole
thing about what's going on
um so i suppose that begs the question
then andrew how
do we get to a position where we we go
to what you're talking about which is
let us be who we are
and do no damage to children and
leave everybody the [ __ ] alone how do we
get to that position
one way i think is
to remind people of history and of
geography
when
certain elements are screaming that they
need this that and the other and they
want to push boundaries further and
further and further
my response is to say have you ever read
any history
do you have any idea of what it's still
like to be gay for example in the vast
majority of countries or on the earth
from the palestinian authorities to
russia to iran
uh
do you have any idea where we've come in
the 1950s 10 000 gay men were fired from
the federal government in a purge of all
homosexuals
uh the government had
surveillance on all of us in the
nation's capital the police had a list
of anyone who had ever had any
homosexual connections people were
killing committing suicide upon being
purged from the feds
it was illegal people were people were
being arrested
we if you were a gay person
ask yourself is there any other time and
place you would ever have wanted to live
except for now in the west and the
answer is no
so can we please get some perspective
can you please see that we are actually
where we always wanted to be
that we we now have the equality we long
sought
our predecessors would be amazed at what
we've done
the idea that we should
further corral coeurs
and lecture the whole world and how they
have to do even more to acknowledge our
existence
it's a form of narcissism that is
self-defeating
it's a historical
and it's an insult to the vast majority
of gay people in the world but who are
also affected by this
the more the extremists in the left on
in the west
push things like
everyone is trans unless proven
otherwise or or
you don't think that that is being
forecast in russia you don't think that
the extremes are being used to actually
hurt
gay people in other countries who are
under much infinitely greater pressure
than we are
i find it i find it morally unserious to
be honest with you
and a luxury belief
you know uh
i grew up in my twenties watching
thousands hundreds of thousands of my
peers die agonizing difficult death
uh we
endured that
uh
we saw things that i hope no one has to
see
and the idea that today someone
misgenders you and you're traumatized
it's an insult to those of us who
actually went through real pain
uh and i am
incredibly depressed by younger gay
generation that does not even
acknowledge
that
contrast
and
and i'm
to be honest fed up with it
andrew i've got a tremendous amount of
sympathy for your position because
my family is south american
i have there's a saying in my family
loft palisas as they're known
and there's there's a saying in my
family whereby the polices they're
either gay or they're ugly right
so we've got a lot of gay men in my
family i had a cousin who passed away uh
from aids when i was nine years old
and this cousin of mine um
we never said
he was it's actually upsetting me now
talking about it
when he died
we
they said that he had um throat cancer
because they didn't want to say to the
family that he died of aids and i still
and even as a kid i remember being angry
because
i felt that when he died he died of
shame because he couldn't even be honest
about his death
so i've always had a tremendous amount
of sympathy for
gay movement gay pride and it's one of
the things that gets me really angry
because
i just see how corporates have just
jumped on this movement and and co-opted
it
and then at the same time you know that
they don't care because in the middle
east
they drop you know the rainbow flag from
from their logos you know that fifa
don't care because they hold a world cup
in qatar and you just think you know
that's disgusting it's utterly
disgusting
yeah
um
i don't want to in any way uh counter
what you just said um
i do remember in my adult lifetime that
we were frustrated that no corporation
would ever touch us yeah
uh so be careful what you ask for um and
i think
uh
but i
you know
part of what has sustained gay people is
our economic power and insofar as our
ability to buy and sell things
can can can help integrate us into the
community then i i don't have a huge
issue with it i agree with you that the
idea that it's anything but utterly
cynical on the part of these
corporations is ludicrous um
but also that they're more enthusiastic
than many of us these bloody flags i
mean please can you stop the flags i
have no idea what all of them mean we
had something called a rainbow flag
which was excruciating enough but
it was the whole point of it was that it
was a metaphor
including everyone we weren't defending
green gays and white gays and purple
gays
it was a rainbow right metaphor and now
they put this brown and black stripe in
it to represent brown and black people
they have pink and blue in it to
represent trans people it looks like a
licorice all sort
and
and again
who who determined that
who the hell decided we all had to have
this new flag i didn't there wasn't a
vote
it's done by these organizations and and
they are captured
by these activists and these activists
have been captured by critical theory
and it's hard to push back especially
when
you tribalize you know
when you're a small community and
someone says something hostile you
perceive as hostile even though it might
just be a counter-argument
your ranks close and you understand how
that dynamic can occur but i agree with
you more of us need to speak up many of
us are
um
and uh i think of katie herzog for
example uh who's a fantastic lesbian
uh
so i'm not
totally gloomy because i think i think
we're gonna take our our identity back i
don't want to take a movement back as
far as i'm concerned the movement is
done
we want our core rights
our job now is to ask ourselves what
lies do we want to live
how do we as gay people contribute
to our society
how can we recognize the great people
that were gay in the past these things
positive
constructive contributive things not
this constant
yelling at people who've already said
yes
it's as if these people cannot take yes
for an answer
uh
and
and we are in a much better place and
look i've lived i'm not that old but
i've lived through this extraordinary
change does it make me
depressed i think we're going backwards
right now but i know how much
further forward we went and we won
again this is what they don't understand
we didn't win marriage equality by
saying if you don't support us you're a
bigot
we actually made the arguments i went
out there i went i don't know how many
pl i went to churches i went to
fundamentalists organizations i went to
catholic universities i went anywhere
anybody asked me to make an argument
respectfully
and you did that for a couple of decades
and we persuaded the middle and we won
and
and we should remember how we did that
we did do we did not do that by hating
on people
we we did that by assuming good faith
and and and and
that also
see the other thing about this is that
if you're really secure as a gay person
you're not constantly waging war on the
world
of everybody who might not be totally
okay with you you let it go
it's the fundamentally insecure
the young and the activists who actually
believe that they have some duty to do
something that they cannot do because
it's already done i call this mlk envy
you know the people people always want i
want to be the martin luther king jr of
my generation well sorry but it's done
the civil rights act is finished you're
too late
uh
and you can invent other ways in which
you think you're changing the world but
at this point you're not you're just
coercing other people so let it go and
get on with your life
what a beautiful message andrew i'm so
glad we had you on the show to talk
about this aspect of things because it's
not it's not a position you hear very
often and i just think that is such a
powerful way of looking at the world not
only in terms of the political issues
that we talk about but actually at the
individual level and it doesn't apply
just to gay people it applies to all of
us like you know the book i've just
written called an immigrants love letter
to the west this is the point i'm trying
to make to people it's like you've got
this is the best place ever to be alive
and all we spend our time doing is
complaining about how terrible
everything is it is
it's mind-boggling but so i'm glad we've
had you on uh it's such a pleasure
talking to you as you know the last
question we always ask is what is the
one thing that we're not talking about
as a society that you think we really
should be
it's a very good question and i've been
trying to think of it since you started
asking i was gonna give away the secrets
that we brief people oh i'm sorry
no it's joking everybody knows everybody
um everybody knows uh
i mean i was immediately thinking i
don't want to be too gay because i've
this has been
yeah too gay anyway it's too late too
late all right she's going to have a
rainbow flag on the cover of the
thumbnail yeah there is
this is something that people will not
talk about
that there is a
methamphetamine epidemic among gay men
that is killing large numbers of gay men
uh
it is the most hideous drug it is taking
people's lives away straight away
uh it is
rampant uh no one talks about it
certainly the gay press barely talks
about it
uh it's implicated in a whole bunch of
things
uh that you can see i mean for example
it's the real story of matthew shepard
not that he was assaulted by two
complete redneck strangers who hated
gays but he was assaulted by his own
boyfriend
or who was on meth for five days
um that makes much more sense in the
situation than than these other things
and and but the ability and the need to
suppress this reality because it's dirty
laundry
because it's telling the truth about
problems that we have it's not helping
gay men either
um
and i really would like to see this
treated with the seriousness it deserves
um
andrew why is it happening i've not
heard about this at all i don't know if
you have friends you have
uh well maybe you're more informed than
i am but why is it happening why is it
specifically in the gay community
it's a good question because it there
are other communities for example in
america it's very much a sort of um
working-class white rural
epidemic as well
um it's just it's it's used in
conjunction with sex it's apparently a
fantastic sort of uh
experience temporarily when you're on
this thing you feel great and powerful
and all the rest of it you have sex for
days on end
um and people talk about that experience
as
super wonderful and they can't go back
to having sex without it
i it
i've just seen it destroy people
friends
and and and and it goes on everyone
acknowledges it privately
it reminds me of the early days of aids
in which people refused to actually
acknowledge because they were scared
that the facts of the matter would
alienate people from gay people
uh well we are alienating ourselves we
are committing suicide in a way
as a community
and you can barely see a word written
about it um and
and i think again it's partly the
media's attempt
well-meant but
coward cowardly
not to air dirty laundry about
minorities when in fact that dirty
laundry needs to be aired in order to
help minorities in order to have
minorities help themselves
um so for example denying that in
america that
the terrible toll of violence on black
people is something that is a function
of white supremacy when it is clearly a
function of
of criminals killing them
uh
is an important thing to remember um
infinitely more
the black americans are killed by
civilians than by cops
and yet we barely mention the former and
we obsess on the latter and i'm not
saying that
killing by cops is something we should
not be concerned about we should but the
perspective is all skewed similarly
in terms of where gay people are instead
of talking about the hatred other people
have for us which they generally don't
except for a few nutters
uh
let's talk about how we can
take care of ourselves
what issues of self-esteem are still
buried within us
the things that that makes it preferable
to go on these drug vendors than just
get on with your life building a
relationship or setting up a home or or
getting a productive career going um it
happens to be a very potent drug too
which seems to
hook people very quickly and be
incredibly hard to recover from
um it has taken a real toll it's still
going on
andrew thank you for for bringing that
up that's not an issue that we've heard
anyone else raise so we really
appreciate it we're going to ask you a
couple of questions from our local
supporters that only they will get to
see but for now thank you so much for
joining us i read the weekly dish every
week it's a monday it comes in monday i
think afternoon my time i really enjoy
it recommend people check it out where
else should people find you online
well the weekly dishes the most uh i'm
on twitter sully dish
um i have a book a collection of my
essays of the last 30 years which came
out in the u.s last year called out on a
limb um which traces my riding for the
last 30 years from
the first arguments to marriage equality
through my arguments against trans
extremism
but also obama
know the entire political the world i'm
not
i don't want people to think that i'm
just a gay journalist i do write about
this topic but no no primarily no no no
no no primarily i'm really in the thick
of american political and cultural and
religious
uh discussion so um
uh
about a limb gives you a sense of
of who i am and where i've been um it's
on amazon
andrew thank you so much for coming on
the show it's been an absolute pleasure
uh don't log off because we'll ask you
questions for our locals and thank you
for everyone watching we hope you've
enjoyed this episode it's been
absolutely brilliant if you want to
watch our episodes they're available on
wednesdays and sundays always coming out
at 7 p.m uk time our raw shows are on
thursday friday and saturday and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
i am now told by critical fears that if
i am not attracted to someone with a
vagina
i'm a bigot
[Music]
you